my wife and i have recently purchased an
assortment pack of soap and we both want
to experience all three bars and we are
not willing to share soap with each
other so we have a little bit of
conundrum how do we share these three
bars of soap so that we each get to
experience all of the smells so this
might be a nice rose smell this might be
some type of i don't know ivory smell i
don't even know if that's a legitimate
smell this might be some type of
sandalwood which is always very nice and
my wife has an idea she says look i'm
going to take these three bars so we're
starting with three bars of soap
and i'm going to divide it into two
equal groups and i said how are you
going to do that and she says well i'm
just going to take out some type of
carving saw or carving knife or who
knows what it is and i'm just going to
cut it right down the middle so write
down this this is my wife cutting the
soap right over here with with her saw
so she's cutting cutting the soap right
over here so she has divided the soap
into two equal groups so she's taken
three bars and she's divided into two
equal groups so the interesting question
here is how many bars of soap do we each
have now and i encourage you to pause
the video and think about that for a
second how many bars of soap do we each
have now
well let's just visualize my share let's
say i take this bottom half right over
here
so this is sal's share of the soap let
me write this out so this is sal's
sal's share
my wife took this top half well what do
i have
well i have
i have one half
i have another one-half and i have
another one-half of a bar so i have
three one-halves of bars of soap or you
could say that i have three
times one-half
three
times one-half bars of soap notice
something very interesting happened here
three divided by two is equal to three
times one-half and we could make it even
more interesting because we know two is
the same exact same thing as two over
one
so three divided by two over one is
equal to three times one half notice we
went from a division to a multiplication
and we took the reciprocal and that
makes complete sense we have three half
bars now what's three times one half
well three times one half
is equal to
is equal to three
three halves so just doing this little
simple
smelly soap example we got a very
interesting result 3 divided by two is
the same thing as three times one half
which is the same thing
as three halves